it takes a big movie studio to make the
Avengers but it doesn't necessarily take
a big movie studio to write a piece of
Avengers fan fiction you see big content
companies largely recognizing that fan
activities are really good for them
because they engage people hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with Reason TV and today we're
talking with Rebecca Tosh net she's a
law professor at Georgetown and she's
also a major player in the organization
for transformative works a non-profit
that looks at copyright in its
application to things like fair use and
fan fiction Rebecca thanks for talking
to us thanks family what is fan fiction
so at its core fan fiction is taking a
text and these days it's usually
copyrighted text make me a book or a
movie or a TV show and saying well what
happened next or what if the main
character was a woman instead of a man
it's part of human nature I think to
tell the stories and retell the stories
are myths
you know the Odyssey the stories of
Coyote they're all what fan fiction was
before there was copyright people told
and retold the story so it is an old
impulse but now because of digital
technology individual users can mirror
perfectly the production quality in many
cases of major studios or producers and
there's copyright so right so there are
technological changes that make
accessibility suddenly possible across
the world so someone who retails Harry
Potter in you know Mumbai can actually
have that rendition recognized elsewhere
and that also implicates copyright which
which does now cover a wide variety of
things and it's automatic and it lasts
for a very long time yeah explain that
copyright is in the Constitution so
there actually was no copyright law the
Constitution authorizes Congress to pass
such a law which it pretty quickly did
and it provided a 14-year term renewable
for another 14 years if the author
survived and it covered books maps and
charts so given how broad copyright is
now it's now possible to say fan fiction
at least some fan fiction is an
infringing derivative work
of the original and in order to deal
with that because I do think it's a
legitimate human activity and especially
in its non-commercial aspect is
something really worth protecting we we
now talk about fair use which is a
principle that allows people to make
fair limited uses of existing works
without permission from the copyright
owner if I want to do a fanfiction of
Fifty Shades of Grey what what
constitutes fair use where I could get
away with well so the traditional
factors include things like whether the
work is commercial or non-commercial so
non-commercial works are just much more
likely to be fair uses in part because
by their very non-commercial 'ti they
show that they're not something that a
market would support so it doesn't
necessarily make sense to charge for
them or you know require compensation
for them since you know they're just non
market activities the nature of the use
so whether it's transformative whether
it adds something new a new meaning or
message and that can be straight up
criticism but it can also actually be in
the form of literary changes then courts
also ask how much did you take of the
original so if you took a little and
built a lot that's gonna favor fair use
what kind of work did you copy so if you
copied an unpublished work that's gonna
be less likely to be fair than copying a
work that's already been fabulously
successful and you know it's easily the
the original is easily accessible and
they've gotten a lot of return for their
money already our producers of content I
mean are they just is it over for them
because of Technology and because of a
shift in power where readers and
consumers now it's so easy to create
your own and in many ways the authors
and producers seem to be insisting on a
particular interpretation of their work
and it's like people are done with that
we want to we want to make our own
decisions about stuff I'd say instead
there's just a bigger spectrum so we
have the multi-million dollar Avengers
right so it takes a big movie studio to
make the Avengers and I love the
Avengers but it doesn't necessarily take
a big movies do to write a piece of
Avengers fanfiction and it
turns out that these can all thrive
together you see big content companies
largely recognizing that fan activities
as opposed to you know commercial
copying without permission are really
good for them because they engage people
talk about what the organization for
transformative works it's a non-profit
what are your goals and what are your
kind of action items so fandom is huge
and much older than we are basically a
group of people that I was a part of
decided that it would be a good idea to
have as part of fandom a non-profit with
the protections afforded by US law for
nonprofits the ability to organize the
ability to you know make educational
presentations and also to go for example
testify in front of the Copyright Office
and trying to actually be a home for
people when they got one of the few
lightning strike challenges because you
know most producers do recognize that
this is fine but you get to the sort of
occasional random strikes against
particular pieces sometimes because of
what they say being offensive to the
copyright owner so this is the classic
case of where if you do you know a Star
Trek piece that some eye was
unflattering to a character you might
you you might be more likely to get in
trouble than if it's just the kind of
run-of-the-mill story right there seems
to be a very serious mismatch between
what people can do and what the law is
talking about do you see within the next
5 years or 10 years
a place where we reach an equilibrium or
is this just going to be a constant kind
of struggle so one thing I've learned is
that predicting what's going to happen
in five years is a terrible idea one
thing that I think may be true is that
the best ideas are not coming from
America anymore in part because our
legislative process is just completely
gridlocked there are good proposals out
there but I don't see the US where can
you talk about an idea from outside the
US so Canada is just finishing up around
a copyright reform it does have some
really disappointing digital lock
provisions that we actually urged on
them and so this is kind of like the
DMCA or
Millennium Copyright Act prohibitions on
breaking and crippling on on ripping
DVDs and things like that
but on the other hand Canada has much
more robust protections for different
kinds of personal uses and has
recognized things like you know
educational copying and even copying for
research where ultimately you're going
to use that research to go out in the
commercial world and make some money but
it's still research it still produces a
social benefit so that's so I think we
can do better and we can do better in
fact just by practices we don't have to
be the kind of litigation happy I will
always assert my rights because I want
to intimidate you culture that we
sometimes come close to having well
we'll leave it there thank you very much
Rebecca touchnet of Georgetown Law
School and the organization for
transformative works thanks very much
for recent TV I'm Nikolas